mari hizo 15 mil mililitros de té para
una fiesta y lo sirvió el té dividido en
8 recipientes iguales su invitado tomó
seis recipientes de té entonces cuánto
te tuvo mar y todavía escribe la
respuesta cuyo número de litros
corresponda y cuyo número de mililitros
corresponda entonces pensemos en esto
ella tenía ocho recipientes y vamos a
visualizar dichos recipientes entonces
dejan los dibujos por aquí
este es el primer recipiente y trata de
dibujar lo más bonito posible
este es un recipiente y pondré la misma
cantidad en cada recipiente misma
cantidad en cada uno entonces déjame
copiar y pegarlo de esta forma entonces
tendremos 45
siete y un octavo
y suponemos que hay la misma cantidad de
fluido en cada recipiente por lo que
entonces dividimos los 15 mililitros de
esto en ocho partes que son las los ocho
recipientes y dicha división es quince
mil mililitros los cuales se dividen
entre ocho ocho grupos iguales u ocho
recipientes iguales como tú lo ves en
las imágenes entonces ocho carga una vez
en 15 lo cual 8 por 1 es 8 le restamos 8
a quien se nos quedan 7 bajamos el 0 el
8 cada 8 veces en el 70 hacemos la resta
nos quedan 6 bajamos el siguiente 0
8 cada vez siete veces en 60 por lo cual
al hacer la resta nos quedan 4 y
finalmente bajamos nuestro último 0 y 8
acá de cinco veces exactamente en 40 por
lo cual tenemos ya un residuo de 0 y
entonces 15.000 dividido entre 8 nos da
un resultado de 1875 por lo que cada uno
de estos ocho recipientes tendrá mil 875
mililitros
entonces si estoy invitado tomo seis
recipientes de té entonces cuánto te le
queda a un amarillo así que si soy
invitado tomo estás de estos seis
recipientes y nos están quedando dos
recipientes a un cuánto te en total va a
haber ahí entonces multiplicamos dos mil
875 mililitros de cada uno por 2
por dos pues aún nos quedan dos
recipientes entonces 7 por 2 14 y
llevábamos una son 15 8 por 2 16
llevábamos una son 7 llevamos 12 por una
y una son 3 y finalmente entonces
tenemos 3 mil 750 mililitros así que
ahora bien es una respuesta que nos está
dando en mililitros pero también nos
interesaría saber cuánto es en litros y
sólo podemos recordar para hacer esto
que mil mililitros es igual a 1 litro
entonces podemos reescribir esto lo cual
de aquí son mililitros de la siguiente
forma tres mil mililitros va a ser igual
a 3 litros
entonces tres mil mililitros más 750
mililitros es lo que tenemos por lo que
podemos decir finalmente que tenemos
tres litros 750 mililitros 3.700 50
litros entonces son 3 litros
tres litros de nuestros tres mililitros
y 750 mililitros y listo